je me rappelle j'ai souffert sang et eau
pour voler votre livre c'était terrible
d'attention à la pivot marguerite duras
marguerite yourcenar
alexandre soljenitsyne d'ormesson jmg le
clézio me levy a trick modiano c'est
vrai qu'il a pas beaucoup de place pour
parler des livres alors autant parler
des livres qu'on aime
hervé bazar et d'art michel tourner il
rencontre de georges brassens et du
général bigeard
évidemment il ya des ruptures de ton
formidable dans cette émission du kof xi
should of just foot - la gueule ilan
kundera philippe labro d'ar men gelowitz
et des accès de tous les maux de la
langue française quel est celui que vous
préférez le plus beau de la langue
française pour un écrivain français tout
au moins depuis 15 ans c'est le mot
pivot apostrophes ina premium la télé
que vous aimez en illimité